she sees somebody in the streets
that she thinks is an arsonist look what
this lady does if you haven't already
no she is not playing also on her
property this is also on her property
yes which
boom has a gun in her hand did you light
anything on fire no ma'am
what are you doing with those glasses on
your head
i smoke you smoke where are your [ __ ]
cigarettes
you don't want to have it right now did
you light anything up on fire
no what's your
that's fine look at the smoke look i
mean just look at what oregon's going
through man it's
the sun should be out now let me ask you
how did he know that he's an arsonist
how does she know how does she know well
matches maybe she's
no cigarettes matches i think he's
guilty i mean
the way he's complying to everything she
says
i haven't seen a guy wear running tights
like that in 20 years well it's pretty
common nowadays i mean skinny jeans we
get that in the office all the time
uh but but
that's why you only have matches on your
hand
what'd you say what do you say there's a
cigarette butt saying smoking cigarette
butts on the highway or something like
that
positive by the way tensions are high in
oregon and anywhere else that uh is
under fire damage do you blame her no
that's on your property good for her
yeah that's something i
i like would you want her as a neighbor
who would want her as a neighbor
if you're watching this right now who
would want somebody like her as your
neighbor would you want somebody like
that as your neighbor
you know i want it to be honest with you
i i think there's a level below where
she's at because she might be doing that
to anybody that does something
she finds suspicious on the ground gun
drawn
are you chewing gum i'd like to know
what happened with that guy
how long ago was this a couple days ago
this is a couple days ago yeah i'd like
to know what happened this couple days
ago that came
and what do you think given the what's
going on in northern california and
oregon and washington
on fire everywhere what do you think
should happen to that guy
if he is guilty of arsenal oh my god the
the
the book the entire book thrown at him
not death penalty but unless people were
killed unless people died from the fire
he started then maybe that's
you know some sort of a homicide charge
or something but no
arsonists are the lowest of the scum
especially in a situation like this
especially as fast i mean they only want
bad things to happen they want these
fires to spread if you're starting it
you are one sick individual you know
what i am curious is what is
the charges and penalties for someone
who starts fire what is that
well if it's an accident it's nothing
it's a misdemeanor like if you're doing
your gender reveal that was going to be
a misdemeanor
for the fire in california but arson's
got to be a felony it has to be
arson's got to be a felony at the level
of what they're doing right now yes
if the person gets caught at the level
they're doing sure accidental maybe a
different story but even that needs to
be held accountable